i just want you all to know that this
hat looked so much better
before i had to put the headphones on
well hello everyone i'm alana and
welcome to my channel where today i am
playing through the resident evil 8
village maiden demo
it did come out at the end of last month
but uh i was in an accident and injured
my hands and haven't been able to play
video games
i'm still not entirely sure that this is
a great idea because
i'm a real wimp when it comes to spooky
games i play all of them
most of my favorite games are survival
horror but i get
very very scared and it is likely that i
will grip the controller really hard and
hurt myself
so you know just so you know what you're
signing yourself up for here
obviously i have made myself
a bit of a vampire woman this is the
most makeup i have worn
in probably the last 12 months couldn't
figure out how to make myself
nine foot six nine foot six
inches tall still working on it i you
know what i'm just gonna
i'm just gonna brighten that a bit why
don't we you know
i do feel like i should mention i have
no idea what this is i don't even know
how long it is
i know it's a demo naturally but i don't
i don't know what
any of the contents of this actually
look like
so what could go wrong really
seems like everything will probably be
fine
okay i can escape a dungeon
oh
what's this
why was that so dramatic
examine to whomever is trying to escape
this place i hope this note will be of
some assistance you don't know me but
you will have to trust me if you want to
survive
first you need to get out of the cell
look around for the way get on your
hands and knees if you must then search
for the thing you'll need to escape it
will be hidden where the least expect
soaked in blood
okay once you get yourself out of the
dungeon you should find yourself in a
room the door there won't lead to
salvation the light will lead you down
the right path
okay don't go through the door go
through the light
you must you might hit a dead end but do
not give up there should be a way to
proceed hidden somewhere once you find
the ladder the only way is up but watch
out don't let them see you
trying to make my escape tonight and
pray that you two make it out alive
oh [ __ ] the brightness kind of made it
look bad
but um i'm gonna stick with it i'm sorry
so what was crouch okay
oh why is there so much noise
oh god
it's not ideal all right
i did not expect that door to open under
any circumstances
jesus oh god
okay
soaked in blood i'm looking for
something soaked in blood
so medicines for keeping livestock alive
interesting okay cool
soaked in blood soaked in blood soaked
in blood soaked in blood
i mean there's a there's a lot of blood
there's so many options for what
could be soaked in blood in here you
know
well that's oh hello
are you are you okay oh gosh
i'd love to
what's all the noises man why
jesus christ sort of sexy though
like i feel like that's more of a sex
thing than a just
blatant torture thing if you ask me
uh-oh
oh my god
there's just so much noise
everywhere i feel like oh you fell over
oh that's
okay well ah
gosh stop with the dramatic
item music jeez
okay bolt cutters is gonna
son of open [ __ ] okay
this is too much goddamn noise man [ __ ]
all right great cool love it great yep
looking for a key a key a key key
all right a lockpick will do
is that is that maybe it is that maybe
all i need from you
[Music]
what is that
i i don't i don't know what that is
okay we're just gonna keep moving then
seems fine
oh god oh god oh god oh god oh god oh
god i wanna i would like to check the
scrap paper again
i think the world's moving in real time
while i'm doing this though
get out of the cell search for the thing
you'll need to escape
done circling blood you should find
yourself in a room the door they won't
lead to salvation the light
will lead you down the right path okay
follow
the light well that's a light
there are several lights could you be
more specific
okay oh there's a hand there
okay
cool
the light the door won't lead me to
salvation you said
[ __ ]
good observation it's very helpful thank
you some of us are trying to escape man
okay is this gonna be it this is gonna
be it's gonna be it
keep going keep going keep going
okay
this seems good read it again
i really hope whoever wrote this is not
lying to me
find the latter the only way up don't
let them see you this is the part where
they're going to start trying to see me
then
and i just need to find a ladder
okay this is the lighting effects are
really good though it is really pretty
i wonder what was through that door
now i'm curious
also i keep worrying because i've had it
with multiplayer games you play call of
duty
and accidentally have your microphone on
in your ps5 controller i keep worrying
that
it's gonna pick up me talking
it's probably not probably not
don't let them see you it said
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god oh my god
garbage go go go go go go go go
i'm just gonna keep crouching because it
makes me more comfortable
just because i feel this is pretty it's
very different
for resident evil
sound sign man
okay
where am i gonna go from here
okay i think this might be tall ladies
like like
room though so
because that looks like the dress she
was [ __ ]
okay oh
do i need that though not really sure
that i did
um the fact that i can't hide in these
closets
in my mind means that i'm either safe or
whatever is going to happen here is
scripted
so let me kind can open this one
also no
[ __ ]
oh [ __ ] there's so many ways to go
[ __ ]
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
okay that's locked oh god oh god oh god
somebody oh
i just don't know whether to be turned
on or scared
pretty lady
[ __ ]
you guys see anyone that's probably
where i gotta get to right
oh my gosh apparently i got quoted by
some like swedish news outlet
for uh my step on me tweet about her
okay okay okay okay
where's the [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh my god maybe it's just best to run no
it's
don't let them see if they see me at all
i'm probably screwed
[ __ ] i'm terrified
this makes me so excited though i love
resident evil games i really do
[Laughter]
i agree same queen
but like that house at the start of re7
with jax is chasing the whole [ __ ]
time
[ __ ] terrifying it said to follow the
light so i followed the light
surely this won't work didn't [ __ ]
think so
oh god
actually i think that crouching did work
with jack so maybe it would work with
this i don't know
ah blood excellent
okay
um okay oh god why does it keep sounding
like dawson
opening and closing right [ __ ] next
to me dude oh [ __ ]
okay it's gonna need a key maybe
ah that's it maybe trying to tell me
that's the door i have to leave for
oh i need to find a way out
from in here
maybe that room has a key in it the last
room the big one
that's a shame
i did not want to go back there uh-huh
okay okay
you have secrets
why would it
what the [ __ ] does that do all right
thanks but why
it seems like it's the only thing in
here
what i can tell
can i just just kick that out could we
just kick that out
not terribly surprised that that didn't
work necklace
my tracks um
bolt cutters no okay
i gotta [ __ ] head back out i would
also like to like
is there anything else that i can do
with this stuff
this seems to just be a necklace you
know
is this you know because sometimes
resident evil stuff like aha
what do i need that for though it's
gonna be yeah just
resident evil [ __ ] this doesn't have
anything like that
doesn't seem to okay
a maron eye huh
i don't i don't want to i just don't
want to
you know
she coming downstairs
certainly sounds like it's getting
closer but not from the direction i
would have expected
what the [ __ ]
i think there's either gonna be
something down here
or
there was like a painting or something
that had a face on it i'm thinking that
maybe i have to put the
the eye in the face
i think that was up here maybe
i don't know how far back it was
could you just chill okay this is gonna
be it this is gonna be it
for sure right i never went that way i
wonder if i was supposed to
okay let's put the i in here
okay cool
okay okay
the wine making techniques of castle
dimitri rescue can be traced back as far
as the 15th century long before the
current occupants of the castle
okay special ornate bottle decorated
with
intricate silver flowers that means
you're going to want me to find that i
think
probably maybe
i do seems odd
you just open all of these is it gonna
be in one of these
key
okay
the courtyard that means that's gonna be
that key that i need oh i'm scared to
[ __ ] go back out though
it can't it can't have been this chill
there's just no way
i'm screwed
something terrible is going to happen um
i've never been more certain
that's how big she is [ __ ] damn
she's huge
i want to go look at it surely
i can just stare at it a bit you know oh
she's really tall
she's gonna be terrifying when we see
her
oh my god okay i just want to check
what's over this way before i head down
there
because
i figure maybe there's a chance that i
need to grab something else
before i can leave
[ __ ] dude no
okay this could just be the world being
fleshed out
i could be completely wrong okay i think
i am
i just don't want to go downstairs i
i have a great time i got out
everything's fine
i'm just i'm enjoying myself looking at
the tall lady's pretty dress
and
what if i just hide under my own hat
it looks so stupid
okay okay
i've never been more sure that i'm about
to get [ __ ] than i am right now i'm
watching you
okay and they stopped all the music
is she like right there oh [ __ ]
this isn't the right room [ __ ]
i don't remember which [ __ ] door it
is
oh god what the [ __ ]
oh my god uh hey um okay oh jesus
she cute though too it's fine it's okay
well
that seems like that that was enough for
you probably you've had a bit to eat
jesus christ
get the [ __ ] away from me
so we finally meet
the problem is i was into it
[Music]
oh why am i like this